tison je suis très heureuse pour te
faire du sport trois semaines tu fermes
et panis ameuté tombe ça permet de
publier mon stress et j'aime qu'à fermer
faute de comportement
un bon raisonnement al hamedi les hommes
pensent à quelqu'un de tout ce qui vient
que le sport l aide pour les lieux c'est
la voix olivades un gay bas beaucoup de
travail
six heures de travail et justement le
progrès qu'elle a fait grâce à sa
ténacité
depuis trois ans donc aller double
championne de france sur 100 m haies
lancer de poids pour les jeux de musique
dont j'ai ramené deux médailles d'or au
long cette patate hugo je souhaiterais
comme entendre deux jours de la
marseillaise je pleurais très fier c'est
la seule médaille d'or qu'on a eue avec
le sport adapté
talant vie elle est capable de télé je
le regarde autrement tard comme copains
en tout cas des incapables
moi je suis pas une fan taré mais moi je
veux être faire le sport comme poumon
je veux qu'ils me traitent comme comme
comme je les respecte